this looks like it's a little less
douchey I'm more a little less little a
little more a little more handed to do
doable oh yeah nope that ain't right
okay
nope okay walk nope walk walk there we
go okay I see I see
and then jump uh-huh jump jump easy
peasy lemon squeeze me
Oh almost had that one almost had that
one almost had that see like I said easy
Peas me easy
Oh whoopsies whoopsies almost had that I
know I had beginner's luck on that first
run there and I won't I won't get that I
won't get that distance again I almost
had it easy Peas me easy okay see it's
like beginner's luck and then luck runs
out why where's my double jump where's
my double jump where's my double jump
what Oh because oh I see I'm falling off
first which I'm trying not to do but
because I'm so close to the edge it's
like I'm falling first which I shouldn't
do got it got it got it ah see even then
I fell I get it I get it it's not the
game being broken it's a little the game
being broken but it's also me how did I
do
so good that first run hello friend okay
[Music]
I'm gonna get through this game I'm
gonna get through this game oh you know
I'm again I'm not gonna button oh you
scared me
oh okay that's an area
scary whoa that's how you beat that
whoops whoops yeah how do you how do you
I'm confused a bit yeah how do you guys
got a go for it like as fast as you can
no stop be stop
yeah oh man how would I kid I don't
think I can jump fast enough wait a
minute mama mo mo mo think of that maybe
this is a little [ __ ] me me me me mo
mo mo mo mo me mo think maybe this is
just a little bit [ __ ] just barely
get on the ledge you say oh I can just
barely do a lot of things like function
as a human eat my meals completely
follow a nutritional guide run a YouTube
channel trust me I can barely do a lot
of things no one as gets comes to doing
it completely well well well some absurd
levels of precision it's demanding a man
I don't like it I only got I've only got
disappointing levels of precision not
not extreme not absurd my levels of
precision are precipitous at best the
margin for error is just a little too
tight I see it does go slow enough that
I could do that action
oh well I gotta get on there first well
po boy watch this [ __ ]
watch this [ __ ] nope well I am sucking
Wow okay
nah I can't even get Terra people I've
lost the above Frick I've lost the
ability to get there Oh
oh hell yeah ah you tip sprinkle bag god
dammit god dammit god damn you just damn
you to hell
whoa okay how how what I can't there's
no way that there's just no way that
there's no way there's no way okay there
was away ah I don't like you
[Music]
what's that red up there what's that red
it looks like the only way I could go
but I don't like it I like it
woo woo woo what is that do nothing
great I didn't trust it I didn't want to
trust it I really didn't want to trust
it alright oh you titty sack oh you sack
of tits oh you big anime boob oh you big
swing an anime boob
oh you poopy pants mother humper god I
keep I keep fiddling before I even have
a chance to be bad I'm just three bad
failing oh I got this yes okay how's
this gonna [ __ ] me
House is gonna broke me I can't wait no
there's no way that that is impossible
there's no way there's no way right I'm
not a big dumb idiot I mean I am but
there's no way and the button is there
but I don't trust that button
[Music]
[Laughter]
you do drop go to hell go to hell oh you
dick you dick I had you dick you dick oh
my god big swinging dick big swinging
anim dick Oh long ago with your big
swinging anime boobs ah you dillweed you
dick hole I've got I haven't got enough
dick related names to call you I'll you
sack of poo okay
how do i the dick this sheer magnitude
of their dick a jury is beyond anything
I could comprehend the girth the girth
the girth the sheer unadulterated girth
on that dick a tree ah all right here we
go
how what excuse me
what's up recommend oh ah that's that's
peculiar
ah okay so I can jump again in that okay
well it's not really gonna help me cuz
I'm still so gonna fail but you know is
what is oh wait a minute wait a minute
wait whoa whoa how would I what I what
is it gonna give me another jump after I
get out of there or something cuz I
would have to have another jump like I
would have to have another jump there's
maybe maybe if I don't jump out of if I
just fall out but then I wouldn't have
enough what I owe it does give me
another jump but even that is good oh
wait is that a button wait a minute Oh
oh my go good golly okay alright okay
that that's a button right okay so I
just gotta shoot that I've gotta shoot
that right that's that's the only way
through this right I've got to be able
to shoot that so if I shoot that oh oh
that does help that does help good god
okay all right
eyyy eyyy I don't like this it's
coordinated action that I I don't I
don't have that coordination and what if
I just like get used to shooting these
at the same time how about that I think
that's gonna help me probably not okay
you're probably right
oh boy almost almost so I just got to do
these at the same time yes yes I hate
this this is awful I know I don't want
to oh god I don't want to do that that
is the worst thing I've ever seen in my
life that is the worst thing I've ever
seen
okay I don't like this how in oh boy
okay what I don't trust that fruit okay
[Laughter]
no you dill weed and a half
oh you dill weed oh you dill weed
ah [ __ ] okay getting better day by day
just gotta take it day off [ __ ] yeah she
a she
into an old man playing this game very
easy to do lose sight of your youth and
just fall into the ever-loving trap of
Decca tree death by fruit you tip you
nipply nip you nipply nip you nip tastic
nipple oh oh really oh really oh really
new ways to die oh I didn't go far
enough back ah God alas it is what we
have and we have what it is which is
stupid and and dumb but it's ours so we
love it just the same
okay ooh okay wait a minute wait wait
whoa away whoa wait
then I was so close
oh no okay
the Ditka tree I know I know who the
[ __ ] tree it's bad everybody it's bad
okay so I just gotta treat this as if
there's nothing wrong haha that feels
good oh that feels good oh that feels
good alright oh that feels good that
feels real hard oh there's a lot of
blood Clint's coming out here oh you
better believe my chair is halfway up my
own ass right now I am so clenched
I am so unbelievably clinched oh that
feels good okay now how can I ruin it
how can I ruin it how can I ruin this
who's gonna ruin this for oh well that's
not good oh oh oh mini-boss I see okay
oh I win all right I don't like this
where ALP I didn't like it enough just
to slam my face into the stupid okay mmm
yes okay
don't dick me over what do you do it
what are you gonna know ah how do you
explain yourself how do you explain
yourself you can't you can't
you're just douche straight to the point
you're douche oh my god I'm never gonna
be able to do this not in a million
years not in a million million million
years not in a ye lien years not in a
million years oh my goodness gravy I'm
good why can't the shoot button not be
next to the jump button why couldn't it
be anywhere else on this stupid keyboard
of mine oh I hate you
uh-uh no never gonna be able to get it
never never gonna be able to get it
never never in a million years when do
you guys see me ever gonna be able to
get this I am never gonna be able to get
this are you gonna do huh what can i
what do i do oh I see ah I see I see now
with my ah hopes oh come on but I saw I
thought the save would count Oh shitty
dicks that's an illusion it's all an
illusion it's all a farce oh it's a
farce it's a force I had that I lost it
the easy part I actually make my jump
and then I just don't get it
ah that's so like me that's such a
markiplier move oh god the save just
doesn't count of course it doesn't okay
so the save doesn't count but I'm doing
it anyway just cuz it feels good
yes
Oh Oh baby baby baby
[Music]
[Laughter]